So, this person shared an article from Dr. Judy Micovitz about HIV and retroviruses.
So it was really on retroviruses and in mRNA viruses and how absolutely dangerous they
are to our body.
So if this is the question, maybe the things in this article are all news.
I know you're familiar with the work of Dr. Judy, it's a long article but touches on potential
cause of so many things including cancer, chronic life, etc.
Wondering if any of the substances you test for us would be antiretrovirals as she mentioned
as effective natural treatments.
So effective antiretrovirals, number one category of effective antiretrovirals is to really
to stimulate what are called T-reg cells.
So a T-reg cell is an immune cell that calls the immune response.
So what happens with retroviruses and mRNA vaccines, like the vaccine that was recently
pushed, it is still being pushed, it stimulates an immune response that could be a hyper immune
response that could really damage cells and could actually lead to an autoimmune disorder
where you're making antibodies against self-tissue.
So in order to combat that, you want to up-regulate your T-reg cells or also called TH3 cells.
So your T-regulator cells are, that's what reg is short for regulation, it regulates your
immune system.
So it calms a TH1 response and calms a hyper TH2 response.
So the benefit of that is during an autoimmune phase or a viral phase, you can be damaging
self-tissue and by stimulating T-reg cells, you're calming that autoimmune response down.
So what are some natural things that calm that down, that are natural T-reg stimulators?
Well, vitamin D is probably your most known T-reg stimulator, but most of your flaminowaves
that we've spoken about for pain relief that we've spoken about for inflammation can help
balance T-reg too because they increase the inflammatory phase in the immune system.
So they decrease inflammatory cytokites, most known as interleukin-6 also interleukin-17.
So those are the inflammatory immune responses that you want to calm and your T-reg system
will do that.
So what would you use for natural T-regulation, stimulation, one would mean vitamin D, another
would be all your flaminowaves which are the, which are curcumin, resveratrol, EGCG from
great T-extract in your order, corsetin, your stingy nettle, things like that that you
would use to decrease inflammation will also do beneficial.